The following is a conversation
with Stuart Russell.
He's a professor of computer science
at UC Berkeley and a coauthor of a book
that introduced me and millions of
other people to the amazing world of AI
called artificial intelligence
and modern approach.
So it was an honor for me to have this
conversation as part of MIT course and
artificial general intelligence and
the artificial intelligence podcasts.
If you enjoy it, please
subscribe on Youtube, Itunes,
or your podcast provider of choice,
or simply connect with me on Twitter
at Lex Friedman, spelled f, r I. D.
And now here's my conversation
with Stuart Russell.
So you've mentioned in
1975 in high school,
you've created one year first
AI programs that play chess,
where you ever able to build a program
that beat you at chess or another board
game? Uh, so my program
never beat me at chess.
I actually wrote the
program at Imperial College.
I used to take the bus every Wednesday
with a box of cards this big,
uh,
and shoved them into the card reader and
they gave us eight seconds of CPU time.
It took about five seconds to read
the cards in and compile the code.
So we had three seconds, a CPU time,
which was enough to make one move,
you know,
with a not very deep search.
And then we would print that move out
and then we have to go to the back of the
queue and wait to feed the cards. And
again, how deep was the search? Well,
I were talking about the move to move.
So now I think we got a,
we got an eight move,
eight depth fleet with Alpha Beta and we
had some tricks of our own about a move
ordering and some pruning of the tree.
And,
but you were still able to
beat that program? Yeah, yeah.
I was a reasonable chess
player in my youth.
I did an a fellow program,
uh, and a backgammon program.
So when I got to Berkeley,
I worked a lot on what
we call Meta reasoning,
which really means
reasoning about reasoning.
And in the case of a game playing program,
you need to reason about what parts of
the search tree you're actually going to
explore. Because the search
tree is enormous, you know,
bigger than the number of atoms
in the universe. And, and uh,
the way programs succeed and the way human
succeed is by only looking at a small
fraction of the search tree.
And if you look at the right fraction,
you played really well.
If you look at the wrong fraction,
if you waste your time thinking about
things that are never going to happen,
the moves and no one's ever going to make,
then you're going to lose cause you,
you won't be able to figure
out the right decision.
So that question of how machines can
manage their own computation, how they,
how they decide what to think
about is the reasoning question.
And we developed some methods for doing
that and very simply the machine should
think about whatever thoughts are
going to improve its decision quality.
We were able to show
that both for a fellow,
which is a standard to play game and uh,
for backgammon,
which includes a dice roll.
So it's a to play a game with uncertainty.
For both of those cases,
we could come up with algorithms that
were actually much more efficient than the
standard Alpha Bita search,
uh,
which chest programs at the time were
using and that those programs could beat
me.
And I think you can see the same basic
ideas in Alphago and Alpha zero today.
The way they explore the tree is using a
form of matter reasoning to select what
to think about based on how
useful it is to think about it.
Is there any insights you can describe
without Greek symbols of how do we select
which paths to go down? There's
really two kinds of learning going on.
So as you say,
Alphago learns to evaluate board position.
So it can,
it can look at a goal board ended actually
has powerfully a superhuman ability
to instantly tell how
promising that situation is.
To me, the amazing thing
about Alphago is not that
it can be the world champion, whether
its hands tied behind his back, but,
uh,
the fact that
if you stop it from searching
altogether, Susie, okay,
you're not allowed to do
any thinking ahead, right?
You can just consider each of your
legal moves in and look at the resulting
situation and evaluate it. So what
we call a, a depth of one search.
So just the immediate outcome of your
moods and decide if that's good or bad.
That version of Alphago
can still play at a professional level,
right?
And human professionals
is sitting there for five,
10 minutes deciding what to do
and Alphago in less than a second
can't instantly intuit what is the right
move to make based on its ability to
evaluate positions. Um,
and that is remarkable. Um,
because you know, we don't have
that level of intuition about go,
we actually have to think
about the situation. So anyway,
that capability that,
um,
Alphago has is one big part
of why it beats humans.
The other big part is that
it's able to look ahead.
40 50 60 moves into the future.
And
you know,
if it was considering all possibilities,
40 or 50 or 60 moves into the
future, that would be, you know,
10 to the 200 possibilities. So way,
way more than atoms in the
universe and and so on.
So eats very,
very selective about what it looks at.
So let me try to give you an intuition
about how you decide what to think about
is a combination of two things.
One is how promising it is,
right? So if you're already
convinced that a movie is terrible,
there's no point spending a lot more time
convincing yourself that it's terrible
because it's powerfully not going
to change your mind. So the,
the real reason you think it's because
there's some possibility of changing your
mind about what to do,
right?
And is that changing of mind
that would result then in,
in a better final action
in the real world.
So that's the purpose of thinking is
to improve the final action in the real
world.
And so if you think about a move
that is guaranteed to be terrible,
you can convince yourself as terrible.
And you're still not going to change
your mind, right? But on the other hand,
you were suppose you had a
choice between two moves.
One of them you've already figured out
is guaranteed to be a draw, let's say.
And then the other one
looks a little bit worse.
Like it looks fairly likely that if you
make that move you're going to lose.
But there's still some uncertainty
about the value of that move.
There is still some possibility that
it will turn out to be a win. Right?
Then it's worth thinking about that.
So even though it's less promising
on average than the other move,
which is guaranteed to be a draw,
there's still some purpose in thinking
about it because there's a chance that
you will change your mind and and
discover that in fact it's a better move.
So it's a combination of how good
the move appears to be and how much
uncertainty there is about its value.
The more uncertainty,
the more it's worth thinking
about because as a higher upside,
if you want to think of it that way.
And of course in the beginning
machine,
the Alphago zero formulation,
it's everything is
shrouded in uncertainty.
So you really swimming in a sea of,
uh, uncertainty. So it had benefits.
You too, I mean actually following
the same process as you described,
but because you're so
uncertain about everything,
you basically have to try a
lot of different directions.
Yeah. So, so the, the early parts
of the search tree, a fairly bushy,
um, that it will, it will look in
a lot of different possibilities,
but fairly quickly the degree of
certainty about some of the moves. I mean,
if a movie's really terrible, you'll
pretty quickly find out, right?
You lose half your pieces or half your
territory and uh, and then you'll say,
okay, this, this is not worth
thinking about anymore. And then,
so a further down the tree
becomes very long and narrow and,
uh, you're, you're following
various lines of play.
10, 20, 30, 40, 50 moves
into the future. And, um,
that's again, it's something that the
human beings have a very hard time doing.
Uh, mainly because they just
lack the short term memory.
You just can't remember a sequence
of moves that's 50 movies long. Uh,
and you can't do, you can't
imagine the board correctly, uh,
for that money moves into the future.
Of course the top
players, I'm much more familiar with
chess, but the top players probably have,
they have echoes of the same kind of
intuition instinct that in a moment's time
alpha go applies when they see a board.
I mean,
they've seen those patterns. Human
beings have seen those patterns before.
At the top of the grand master level,
it seems that there is some
similarities or maybe it's,
it's our imagination creates a
vision of those similarities.
But it feels like this kind of pattern
recognition that the Alphago approaches
are using is similar to what human
beings at the top level or using.
I think there's, uh,
there's some truth to that,
but not entirely. I mean, I think the,
the extent to which human grandmaster
can reliably rec instantly recognize the
right move and instantly recognize
the value of a position. Uh,
I think that's a little bit overrated.
But if you sacrifice a queen for example,
I mean there's these,
there's these beautiful games
of chess with Bobby Fischer,
somebody where it's
seeming to make a bad move.
And I'm not sure there's a perfect degree
of calculation involved where they've
calculated all the possible thing that
happened. But there's an instinct there,
right?
That somehow adds up to,
yeah, I think what happens is you, you,
you get a sense that there's some
possibility in the position, uh,
even if you make a weird looking
move, um, that it opens up some,
some lines of,
of calculation that otherwise
would be, uh, definitely bad. And,
um,
and is that intuition that
there's something here in
this position that might,
uh, might yield at when don the site
and then you follow that, right?
And,
and in some sense when a,
when a chess player is following a line
in his or her mind there they mentally
simulating what the other person is going
to do while the opponent is going to
do. And they can do that as long
as the moves a kind of forced,
right. As long as there's,
you know, there's a,
a fort we call a forcing variation where
the opponent doesn't really have much
choice how to respond and then you see
if you can force them into a situation
where you win. You know, we
see plenty of mistakes, uh,
even even in grandmaster games where
they just miss some simple three,
four, five move, a
combination that, you know,
it wasn't particularly apparent in,
in the position but was still there.
That's the thing that makes us human.
Yup.
So when you mentioned that in Othello,
those games or after some matter reasoning
improvements and research was able to
beat you,
how did that make you feel?
Part of the metal reasoning
capability that it had? Um,
[inaudible] was based on learning and,
um,
and you could sit down the next day and
you could just feel that it had got a
lot smarter and all of a sudden
you really felt like, you know,
sort of pressed against
the wall because a, it was,
it was much more aggressive and,
and was totally unforgiving of,
of any minor mistake that you
might make. And, uh, and Ashley's,
it seemed understood the
game better than I did.
And Garry Kasparov has
this quote where it, um,
during his match against deep blue,
he said he suddenly felt that there was
a new kind of intelligence across the
board.
Do you think that's a scary
or an exciting possibility?
Kasparov and for yourself
in the context of chess?
Purely sort of in this, like
that feeling, whatever that is.
I think it's definitely an exciting
feeling. You know, this is what made me
work on AI in the first place,
was as soon as I really
understood what a computer was,
they wanted to make it smart.
You know, I started out with,
the first program I wrote was for the
sink layer programmable calculator. Uh,
and I think you could right at 21 step,
uh,
algorithm that was the biggest program.
You could write something like that. Um,
and do a little arithmetic calculation.
So I sent think are implemented
Newton's method for square roots,
a few other things like that. Um,
but then, you know, I thought, okay,
if I just had more space,
I could make this thing intelligent.
And so I started thinking about Ai and,
and I think the,
the,
the thing that's scary is not,
is not the chess program
because, you know,
chess programs, they're not in the
taking over the world business. Uh,
but
if you extrapolate,
you know, there are things about chess
that don't resemble the real world, right?
We know,
we know the rules of chess.
The chess board is completely visible
to the program where, of course,
the real world is not most,
most of the real world is he's not
visible from wherever you're sitting,
so to speak. And, uh,
to overcome those kinds of problems,
you need qualitatively
different algorithms.
Another thing about the real world
is that, you know, we, we regularly
plan ahead on the timescales involving
billions or trillions of steps.
Um, now we don't plan those
in detail, but you know,
when you choose to do a phd at Berkeley,
that's a five year commitment and that
amounts to about a trillion motor control
steps that you will eventually
be committed to including
going up the stairs,
opening doors, drinking water type. Yeah,
I mean every finger movement while you're
typing every character of every paper
and the thesis and everything.
So you're not committing and advanced
to the specific motor control steps,
but you're still reasoning on a
timescale that will eventually reduce to
trillions of motor control actions
and a,
so for all of these reasons,
you know,
Alphago and deep blue and so on don't
represent any kind of threat to humanity,
but they are a step towards it,
right?
And progress in AI
occurs by essentially removing one by one.
These assumptions that make problems easy,
like the assumption of complete
observability of the situation, right?
We remove that assumption.
You need a much more complicated
kind of computing design.
It needs,
it needs something that actually keeps
track of all the things you can't see and
tries to estimate what's going on.
Uh,
and there's inevitable
uncertainty in that,
so it becomes a much more
complicated problem. But you know,
we are removing those assumptions.
We are starting to have algorithms that
can cope with much longer timescales.
They can cope with uncertainty that
can cope with partial observability.
And so each of those steps
sort of magnifies by a
thousand the range of things
that we can do with AI systems.
So the way I started in a,
I wanted to be a psychiatrist for a long
time and energy and the mine in high
school and of course program
and so on. And I showed up, uh,
university of Illinois to an
AI lab and they said, okay,
I don't have time for you, but
here's a book, Ai, a modern approach.
I think it was the first edition at the
time. Here it go, go, go learn this.
And I remember the lay of the land was
all, it's incredible that we solved chess,
but we'll never solve go.
I mean it was pretty certain that go in
the way we thought about systems that
reason was impossible to solve
and now solve this as a very,
I think I would have said
that it's unlikely we could
take the kind of algorithm
that was used for chess and just get
it to scale up a and work well for go
and at the time what we thought
was that in order to solve go,
we would have to do something similar
to the way humans manage the complexity
you go, which is to break it
down into kind of sub games.
So when a human thinks about a go board,
they think about different parts of the
board as sort of weakly connected to
each other and they think about,
okay, within this part of the board,
here's how things could go in that
part of what his, how things could go.
And then you try to sort of couple those
two analyses together and deal with the
interactions and maybe revise your views
of how things are going to go in each
park in. Then you've got maybe five,
six, seven, 10 parts of the board.
And,
um,
that actually resembles the real world
much more than Chester's because in the
real world, you know, we
have work, we have home life,
we have sport, you know, whatever
different kinds of activities, you know,
shopping.
These all are connected to each other,
but they're weakly connected. So
when I'm typing a paper, you know,
I don't simultaneously have
to decide which order I'm
going to get the, you know,
the milk and the butter, you know,
that doesn't affect the typing.
But I do need to realize,
okay,
but if an this before the shops close
is cause I don't have any ticket.
You don't have any food
at home. Right, right.
So there's some weak connection but
not in the way that chess works where
everything is tied into a
single stream of thought.
So the thought was that go to solve go,
we'd have to make progress on stuff
that will be useful for the real world.
And in a way Alpha goes a little bit
disappointing, right? Because the,
the program designed for Alpha was
actually not that different from,
from deep blue or,
or even from Arthur Samuel's checker
playing program for the 1950s.
And in fact, the, so the two things
that make Alphago work is one,
one is his amazing ability to
ability to evaluate the positions.
And the other is the Metta reasoning
capability, which, which allows it to,
to explore some paths in the tree very
deeply into abandoned other paths very
quickly. So this word
matter reasoning, uh,
while technically correct
inspires perhaps the,
the wrong degree of power
that Alphago has. For example,
the word reasonings as a powerful word.
So let me ask you sort of the,
you were part of the
symbolic AI world for awhile.
Like learn AI was, uh,
there's a lot of excellent,
interesting ideas there that
unfortunately met I winter.
And so it,
do you think it re-emerges oh,
so I would say, yeah, it's not
quite as simple as that. So the,
the Ai Winter,
the first winter that was actually
named as such was the one in the late
eighties. And that came about because, uh,
in the mid eighties,
there was a
really a concerted attempt to push
AI out into the real world, uh,
using what was called
expert system technology.
And for the most part,
that technology was just not ready
for prime time. They were trying,
uh, in many cases to do a
form of uncertain reasoning,
a judge judgment, combinations
of evidence, diagnosis,
those kinds of things,
which was simply invalid.
Uh,
and when you try to apply in valid
reasoning methods to real problems,
you can fudge it for small
versions of the problem.
But when it starts to get larger,
the thing just falls apart.
So many companies found that,
uh,
the stuff just didn't work and they were
spending tons of money on consultants
to try and make it work.
And there were other practical reasons,
like, you know, they,
they were asking the companies to
buy incredibly expensive lisp machine
workstations, which were literally
between 50 and $100,000 in,
uh, you know, in 1980 is money, which was,
would be like between 150 and $300,000
per workstation in current prices.
So the bottom line and they weren't
seeing a profit from it. Yeah. Um, they,
they, in many cases, I think
there were some successes.
There's no doubt about that.
But people,
I would say overinvested every major
company was starting an AI department just
like now.
And I worry a bit that we might
see similar disappointments,
not because of the tech.
The current technology is invalid,
but it's limited in its scope. And, uh,
it's almost the, the
duel of the, you know,
the scope problems that
expert systems had.
So what have you learned from that hype
cycle and what can we do to prevent
another winter, for example? Uh, yeah,
so when I'm giving talks these days,
that's one of the warnings that
I give. Uh, so those, those two,
two pot warning slide one
is that, uh, you know,
rather than data being the new
oil data is the new snake oil, uh,
it's a good line. And then,
um, and then the other, uh,
is that we might see a kind of very
visible failure in some of the major
application areas. And I think self
driving cars would be the flagship.
And, uh, I think when
you look at the history,
so the first self driving
car was on the freeway,
uh,
driving itself,
changing lanes overtaking in 1987
and uh,
so it's more than 30 years and that
kind of looks like where we are today.
Right. You know, prototypes
on the freeway, changing
lanes and overtaking. Um, now
I think significant progress has been
made, particularly on the perception side.
So we worked a lot on autonomous
vehicles in the early,
mid nineties at Berkeley, you know,
and we had our own big demonstrations,
you know, we, we put congressmen
into self driving cars and,
and had them zooming along
the freeway. And, uh,
the problem was clearly perception
at the time. The problem.
Yeah.
W in simulation with perfect perception,
you could actually show that you can
drive safely for a long time and even if
the other cars and he's
behaving and so on.
But simultaneously we worked on machine
vision for detecting cars and tracking
pedestrians and so on.
And we couldn't get the reliability
of detection and tracking up to a high
enough particular level,
particularly in bad weather conditions.
A nighttime rain fall.
Good enough for demos,
but perhaps not good enough to cover
the general, the general operation.
The thing about driving
is, you know, so it,
suppose you're a taxi driver
and you drive every day,
eight hours a day for 10 years,
right?
That's a hundred million
seconds of driving, you know,
and any one of those seconds you
could make a fatal mistake. Yeah.
So you're talking about eight
nines of reliability right?
Now,
if your vision system only
detects 98.3% of the vehicles,
right? That's sort of, you know,
one on a bit nines of reliability.
So you have another seven
orders of magnitude to go.
And um, and this is what people
don't understand. They think, oh,
because I had a successful demo,
I'm pretty much done, but you're,
you're not even within seven
orders of magnitude of being done.
And that's the difficulty.
And it's, it's not the, Oh,
can I follow up white line?
That's not the problem. Right?
We follow a white line all
the way across the country,
but it's the,
it's the weird stuff that happens.
It's sort of the edge cases.
Yeah. The edge case, other
drivers doing weird things.
Um, you know, so if you
talk to Google, right?
So they had,
um,
actually very classical
architecture where, you know,
you had machine vision,
which would detect all the other cars and
pedestrians and the white lines in the
road signs. And then basically that
was fed into a logical database.
And then you had a classical 19
seventy's rule based expert system.
I'm telling you,
okay,
if you're in the middle lane and there's
a bicyclist in the right lane who is
signaling this, then then, then,
then he'd do that. Yeah. Right.
And what they found was that every
day they go out and there'd be another
situation that the rules didn't
cover. You know, so they,
they come to a traffic circle and there's
a little girl riding a bicycle the
wrong way around the traffic circle. Okay,
what do you do? We don't have a rule.
Oh my God. Okay, stop.
And then you, you know,
they'd come back and add more rules and
they just found that this was not really
converging. And, um, and if
you think about it, right? How,
how do you deal with an
unexpected situation,
meaning one that you've never previously
encountered and the sort of the
reasoning required to
figure out the solution.
But that situation has never been
done. It's, it doesn't match any, uh,
previous situation in terms of the
kind of reasoning you have to do. Well,
you know, in chess programs,
this happens all the time.
You're constantly coming
up with situations that you
haven't seen before and you
have to reason about them. And
you have to think about, okay,
here are the possible things I could do.
Here are the outcomes,
here's how desirable the outcomes are.
And then pick the right one. You know,
in the 90s we were saying,
Hey,
this is how you're going to
have to do automated vehicles.
They're going to have to
have a look ahead capability.
But the look ahead for driving is more
difficult than it is for chess because
humans, the other, right,
there's humans in there,
less predictable than chess pieces,
then well then you have an opponent in
chess who's also somewhat unpredictable,
but for example, in chess, you
always know the opponent's intention.
They're trying to beat you, right?
Whereas in driving, you don't know,
is this guy trying to turn left or has
he just forgotten to turn off his turn
signal? Or is he drunk or is he, you know,
changing the channel on his
radio or whatever it might be.
You've got to try and
figure out the mental state,
the intent of the other drivers to
forecast the possible evolutions of their
trajectories. And then you
gotta figure out, okay,
which is the directory for me,
that's going to be safest.
And those all interact with each other
because the other drivers are going to
react to your trajectory.
Um, and so on. So, you know,
they've got the classic
merging onto the freeway,
a problem where you're kind of racing
a vehicle that's already on the freeway
and you're gonna pull ahead of them.
Or are you going to let them go
first and pull in behind and,
and you get this sort of
uncertainty about who's going first.
So all those kinds of things
mean that you need a decision making
architecture that's very different from
either a rule based system or it seems
to me it kind of an end to end neural
network system,
you know,
so just as Alphago is pretty good
when it doesn't do any look ahead,
but it's way, way, way,
way better when it does.
I think the same is going
to be true for driving.
You can have a driving system that's
pretty good when it doesn't do any look
ahead, but that's not
good enough. Um, you know,
and we've already seen multiple deaths
caused by poorly designed machine
learning algorithms that don't really
understand what they're doing. Yeah.
And on several levels, I think.
Uh, so on the perception side,
there's mistakes being made by those
algorithms where the perception is very
shallow on the planning side of
the look ahead, like you said.
And the thing that we
come up against that's
really interesting when you try to deploy
systems in the real world is you can't
think of an artificial intelligence system
as a thing that responds to the world
always.
You have to realize that it's an agent
that others will respond to as well.
So in order to drive successfully,
you can't just try to do
obstacle avoidance, right?
You got and pretend that you're invisible,
right? Are the invisible car, right?
So that way,
I mean,
but you have to assert yet others have
to be scared of you just we're all,
there's this tension,
there's this game.
So we study a lot of
work with pedestrians.
If you approached pedestrians as
purely an obstacle avoidance of you,
you are doing look ahead, is in
modeling the intent that you're, you're,
they're not going to,
they're going to take advantage of you.
They're not going to respect you at
all. There has to be a tension, a fear.
Some amount of uncertainty.
That's how we have Cree,
or at least just have kind of
a a resoluteness right? Yes.
You have to display a certain
amount of resolution is you can't,
you can't be too tentative.
Yeah. And uh, yeah, so the,
the, the solutions then become
pretty complicated, right?
You get into game theoretic
analyses and so we, you know,
at Berkeley now we're working a lot on
this kind of interaction between machines
and humans and that's exciting.
And, uh, so my colleague,
uh, and could drag an actually, you know,
if you,
if you formulate the problem game
theoretically and you just let the system
figure out the solution, you
know, it does interesting.
Unexpected things like
sometimes at a stop sign,
if no one is going first,
right?
The car will actually back up a little,
right.
And just to indicate to the other
cars that they should go, uh,
and that's something it invented entirely
by itself. That's interesting. Right?
There was,
you know,
we didn't say this is the language
of communication at stop signs.
It figured it out.
That's really interesting.
So let me one,
just step back for a second.
Just this beautiful philosophical notion.
So Pamela McCormick in 1979 wrote,
Ai began with the ancho
wish to forge the gods.
So when you think about the
history of our civilization,
do you think that there is
an inherent desire to create,
let's not say gods,
but to create superintelligence?
Is it inherent to us is in our genes,
that the natural arc of human civilization
is to create things that are of
greater and greater power and perhaps,
uh,
echoes of ourselves. So to create
the gods as, as, uh, Pamela said,
if the, maybe, I mean, you know,
we're all, we're all individuals,
but certainly we see over and
over again in history, uh,
individuals who thought
about this possibility,
hopefully when I'm not being
too philosophical here.
But if you look at the arc of this,
you know where this is going
and we'll talk about AI safety.
We'll talk about greater
and greater intelligence.
Do you see that they're in,
when you created the Othello program
and you felt this excitement,
what was that excitement?
Was it excitement of a tinkerer who
created something cool like a clock or was
there a magic or was it more
like a child being born that,
yeah, yeah. So I mean, I
certainly understand that
viewpoint. And if you look at,
um, the light hill report,
um, which was coming,
so in the 70s,
there was a lot of controversy
in the UK about Ai and you know,
whether it was for real
and how much the money,
money the government should
invest. And there was a long,
long story, but the government
commissioned a report by,
by Light Hill who was a physicist and uh,
he wrote a very damning report about Ai,
which I think was the point.
Uh, and uh, he said
that that these are, uh,
you know, frustrated man who unable
to have children, would like to,
to create a and, you
know, create a life, um,
you know, as a kind of
replacement, which I,
which I think is really pretty unfair.
But there is, I mean there,
there is a kind of magic,
I would say you when you,
you build something
and, and what you're
building in is really just,
you're building in some understanding of
the principles of learning and decision
making.
And to see those principles actually
then turn into intelligent behavior
in,
in specific situations.
It's an incredible thing.
And, uh, you know, that
is a naturally going to make you think,
okay,
where does this end?
And so there's a, there's magical
optimistic views of where it ends.
Whatever your view of optimism is,
whatever your view of utopia is
probably different for everybody,
but you've often talk about concerns
you have of how things might go wrong.
So,
uh,
I've talked to a Max Tegmark.
Uh,
there's a lot of interesting
ways to think about AI safety.
You're one of the Seminole people thinking
about this problem amongst sort of
being in the weeds of actually
solving specific AI problems.
You also think about the big
picture of where we're going.
So can you talk about
several elements of it?
Let's just talk about
maybe the control problems.
So this idea of losing the ability
to control the behavior I AI system.
So how do you see that?
How do you see that coming about?
Do you think we can do, uh, to manage it
well?
So it doesn't take a genius to realize
that if you make something that's smarter
than you, you might have a
problem. You know, and Turing,
Alan Turing,
you wrote about this and gave
lectures about this ninth, 19, 51,
he did a lecture on the radio and uh,
he basically says no,
once the machine thinking
method starts, uh, you know,
very quickly they'll outstrip humanity.
And uh,
you know, if we're lucky we might
be able to, I think he says it,
we may be able to turn off the power
at strategic moments, but even so,
our species would be humbled. Yeah.
Actually I think was wrong about that.
Right, because you, you know,
if it's a sufficiently intelligent machine
is not going to let you switch it off.
It's actually in competition with you.
So what do you think is meant?
Just for quick tangent,
if we shut off this super intelligent
machine that our species will be humbled,
I think he means that we would
realize that we are inferior,
right?
That we,
we only survived by the skin of our
teeth because we happen to get to the off
switch, you know, Justin, Justin
time, uh, you know, and if we hadn't,
then, uh, we would have lost
control over the earth. So do you,
are you more worried when
you think about this,
the stuff about superintelligent AI or
are you more worried about super powerful
AI that's not aligned with their
values? So the paperclip, uh,
scenarios kind of, uh, I think, um,
so the main problem I'm working
on is he's the control problem.
The problem of machines pursuing
objectives that are not aligned with human
objectives. And, and this has been,
it has been the way we've thought
about AI since the beginning.
You,
you build a machine for optimizing and
then you put in some objective and it
optimizes right? And,
and, um, you know, we,
we can think of this as the, the king
midas problem, right? Because if you know,
the King Midas put in this objective,
right,
everything I touched turned to
gold and the gods, you know,
that's like the machine. They
said, okay, done. You know,
you now have this power and of course
his food and his drink and his family all
turned to gold and then he's dies,
misery and starvation. And, um,
this is, you know, it's, it's a warning.
It's a failure mode that pretty much every
culture in history has had some story
along the same lines.
You know, there's the,
the genie that gives you three wishes
and you know, third wish is always,
you know, please undo the first
two wishes because I messed up.
And, uh, you know, and when
author Samuel wrote his chest,
his checker playing program,
which learned to play checkers
considerably better than
Arthur Samuel could play
and actually reached a
pretty decent standard.
Uh, no, but we know who was, uh,
one of the major mathematicians
of the 20th century.
He sort of the father of modern
automation control systems.
You know, he saw this and he
basically extrapolated, uh, you know,
as touring did and said,
okay,
this is how we could lose control and,
uh,
specifically that we have to be certain
that the purpose we put into the machine
as the purpose,
which we really desire.
And the problem is we can't do that.
You mean we're not,
it's a very difficult to encode to,
to put our values on paper is really
difficult or you're just saying it's
impossible. Uh, line is,
hey, did you mean the test? So
theoretically it's possible, but, uh,
in practice it's extremely unlikely that
we could specify correctly in advance
the full range of concerns of humanity.
The,
you talked about cultural and transmission
of values I think is how humans to
human transmission of values happens.
Right? Uh, well we learned, yeah. I mean,
as we grow up,
we learn about the values that matter,
how things,
how things should go,
what is reasonable to pursue and
what isn't reasonable to pursue.
Big machines can learn it in the same
kind of way. Yeah. So I think that, um,
what we need to do is to get away from
this idea that you build an optimizing
the sheet and then you
put the objective into it.
Because if it's possible that you might
put in a wrong objective and we already
know there's as possible cause it's
happened lots of times, all right?
That means that the machine should
never take an objective that's given as
Gospel truth because once it takes the,
the,
the objective is Gospel truth,
right?
Then it's the leaves that whatever
actions it's taking in procedure,
that objective are the
correct things to do.
So you could be jumping up and down
and saying, no, you know, no, no, no,
you're going to destroy the world.
But the machine knows what the true
objective is and is pursuing it and tough
luck to you. You know, and this
is not restricted to AI, right?
This is, you know, I think many of
the 20th century technologies, right?
So in statistics you,
you minimize a loss function.
The loss function is exogenously
specified in control theory.
You minimize the cost function
in operations research,
you maximize the reward function. And
so on. So in all these disciplines,
this is how we conceive of the problem.
And it's the wrong problem because we
cannot specify with certainty the correct
objective, right? We need uncertainty.
We the machine to be uncertain about as
objective what it is that it's posted.
It's maximizing favorite idea of years.
Uh, I've heard you say somewhere, uh,
well I shouldn't pick favorites,
but it just sounds beautiful.
We need to teach machines
humility. Uh, yeah. I mean,
that's a beautiful way
to put it. I love it. Um,
but they are humble in it.
They know,
they know that they don't know what it
is they're supposed to be doing and the,
and that, those, those objectives, I mean,
they exist there within us,
but we may not be able to explicate them.
We may not even know,
uh,
you know how we want our future to go.
So you exactly. And the machine, you know,
machine that's uncertain is
going to be deferential to us.
So if we say don't do that well now
the machines learn something a bit more
about our true objectives
because something that it
thought was reasonable in
pursuit of our objective, it turns out
not to be. So now it's learn something.
So it's going to differ because it
wants to be doing what we really want.
And um,
you know,
that that point I think is absolutely
central to solving the control problem.
Yeah. Uh, and it's a
different kind of AI when you,
when you take away this idea that the
objective is known then in fact a lot of
the theoretical frameworks
that we're so familiar with,
you know, mark off decision
processes, a goal based planning,
uh, you know, standard game
tree search, all of these, uh,
techniques actually become in applicable.
Uh,
and you get a more
complicated problem because,
because now
the interaction with the human
becomes part of the problem
cause the human by making choices is
giving you more information about the true
objective and that information helps
you achieve the objective better.
And so that really means
that you're mostly dealing
with game theoretic problems
where you've got the machine and the
human and they're coupled together, uh,
rather than a machine going off
by itself with a fixed objective,
which is fascinating on the machine
and the human level that we,
when you don't have an objective means
you're together coming up with an
objective. I mean, there's a lot
of philosophy that, you know,
you could argue the life doesn't really
have meaning we we together agree on
what gives it meaning.
And we've kind of culturally
create a things that give,
why the heck we are in this earth anyway.
Uh,
we together as a society create that
meeting and you have to learn that
objective.
And one of the biggest,
I thought that's what you were
going to go for a second. Uh,
one of the biggest troubles we run
into outside of statistics and machine
learning and AI and just human
civilization is when, uh,
you look at,
I came from this,
I was born in the Soviet Union and
the history of the 20th century,
we run into the most trouble
us humans when there was a,
uh,
a certainty about the objective and you
do whatever it takes to achieve that
objective with he talking bout
in Germany or communist Russia.
All right.
Yeah, I get into trouble with humans say
with, uh, you know, corporations. In fact,
some people argue that,
you know,
we don't have to look forward to a time
when AI systems take over the world they
already have and they call a corporations,
right?
That corporations happened to be,
uh,
using people as components right now.
Um,
but they are effectively algorithmic
machines and they're optimizing an
objective,
which is quarterly profit
that isn't aligned with
overall wellbeing of the human
race and they are destroying the world.
They are primarily responsible for our
inability to tackle climate change.
Right? So I think that's one way of
thinking about what's going on with,
uh,
with corporations.
But I think the point
you're making is valid.
That there,
there are many systems in the real world
where we've sort of prematurely fixed
on the objective and then decoupled the,
uh,
the machine from those and it's
supposed to be serving. Um,
and I think you see this with government,
right?
Government is supposed to be
a machine that serves people,
but instead it tends to be taken over
by people who have their own objective,
uh,
and use government
to optimize that objective regardless
of what people want. Do, do you have,
do you find appealing the idea of almost,
uh,
arguing machines where you have
multiple AI systems with a clear fixed
objective? We have in government,
the red team and the blue team,
they're are very fixed on their objectives
and they argue and it kind of, uh,
made would disagree,
but it kind of seems to
make it work somewhat that,
uh, the, the, the duality
of it I though, okay,
let's go a hundred years back when
there was still was going on or at the
founding of this country,
there was disagreements and
that disagreement is where,
uh,
so it was a balance between certainty
and forced humility because the power was
distributed.
Yeah. I think that the, um, the,
the nature of debate and
disagreement argument takes,
uh, as a premise, the idea
that you could be wrong,
right?
Which means that you're not necessarily
absolutely convinced that your objective
is, is the correct one. All right? Um,
if you were absolutely,
there'd be no point in having
any discussion or argument
because you would never
change your mind and
there wouldn't be any,
any sort of synthesis or,
or anything like that. So,
so I think you can think
of argumentation as a,
as an implementation of a
form of uncertain reasoning.
Uh, and, um, you know, I, I,
I've been reading recently
about utilitarianism and
the history of efforts to
define in a sort of clear
mathematical way, a,
if you like, a formula for moral
or political decision making.
And it's really interesting that the
parallels between the philosophical
discussions going back 200 years and
what you see now in discussions about
existential risk because yeah,
it's almost exactly the same.
So someone would say,
okay,
well here's a formula for how
we should make decisions, right?
So utilitarian design roughly,
you know,
each person has a utility function and
then we make decisions to maximize the
sum of everybody's utility,
right?
And then people point out,
well, you know, in that case,
the best policy is one that leads
to the enormously vast population,
all of whom are living a life that's
barely worth living, right? And,
and this is called the repugnant
conclusion. And, uh, you know,
another version is, you know, that we,
we should maximize pleasure and
that's what we mean by utility.
And then you'll get people effectively
saying, well, in that case, you know,
we might as well just have everyone
hooked up to a heroin drip, you know,
and they didn't use those words.
But that debate, you know,
was happening in the 19th
century as it is now, uh,
about AI that if we get the formula wrong,
you know,
we're going to have AI systems working
towards an outcome that in retrospect
would be exactly wrong.
Do you think theirs has beautifully put,
so the echoes are there, but do you think,
uh, I mean if you look at Sam Harris,
is our imagination worries about the
Ai version of that because of the,
uh,
the,
the speed at which the things going
wrong in the utilitarian context could
happen? Yeah. Is that, is that a
worry for you? Yeah, I think that,
you know, in most cases,
not in all, but if we,
if we have a wrong political idea,
you know,
we see it starting to go wrong
and we're, you know, we're,
we're not completely stupid.
And so we said, okay, that was,
maybe that was a mistake. Uh,
let's try something different.
And,
and also we're very slow and inefficient
about implementing these things and so
on.
So you have to worry when you have
corporations or political systems that are
extremely efficient.
But when we look at AI systems or
even just computers in general, right?
They have this different characteristic
from ordinary human activity in the
past.
So let's say you were a surgeon,
you had some idea about how to
do some operation, right? Well,
and let's say you were wrong,
right?
That that way of doing the operation
would mostly kill the patient. Well,
you'd find out pretty quickly
that like off to three,
maybe three or four tries. Right? But
that isn't true for
pharmaceutical companies because
they don't do three or four
operations.
They,
they manufacturer three or 4 billion pills
and they sell them and then they find
out maybe six months or a year later that,
oh,
people are dying of heart attacks
or getting cancer from this drug.
And so that's why we have the FDA,
right?
Because of the scalability of
pharmaceutical production and you know,
and there have been some
unbelievably bad episodes
in the history of pharmaceuticals
and adulteration of,
of products and so on that debt have
killed tens of thousands or paralyzed
hundreds of thousands of people.
Now with computers,
we have that same scalability problem
that you can sit there and type for I
equals one to 5 billion do,
right?
And all of a sudden you are having
an impact on a global scale.
And yet we have no FDA,
right?
There's absolutely no controls at all
over what a bunch of undergraduates with
too much caffeine can do to
the world. And uh, you know,
we look at what happened with Facebook,
well,
social media in general and
click through optimization.
So you have a simple feedback algorithm
that's trying to just optimize,
click through, right? That
sounds reasonable. Right?
Cause you don't want to be feeding
people ads that they don't care about.
I'm not interested in,
and you might even think of that
process as simply adjusting the,
the feeding of ads or news articles or
whatever it might be to match people's
preferences. Right. Which
sounds like a good idea,
but in fact that isn't how
the algorithm works, right?
You make more money, the
algorithm makes more money. If
it can better predict what people are
going to click on it cause then it can
feed them exactly that.
Right?
So the way to maximize click true is
actually to modify the people to make them
more predictable.
And one way to do that is to feed them
information which will change their
behavior and preferences towards
extremes that make them predictable and
whatever is the nearest extreme or
the nearest predictable point, uh,
that's where you're going to end up.
And the machines will force you there.
Now, and I think there's a
reasonable argument to say that this,
among other things is contributing to the
destruction of democracy in the world.
And where was the
oversight of this process?
Where would the people saying,
okay,
you would like to apply this
algorithm to 5 billion people on the,
on the face of the earth?
Can you show me that it's safe?
Can you show me that it won't have
various kinds of negative effects? No.
There was no one asking that question.
There was no one placed between,
you know, the undergrads with too
much caffeine and the human race.
Well it's just they just
did it as, but some, uh,
we're outside of the scope of
my knowledge. So economists
would argue that the,
what is it?
The invisible
hand. So the, the capitalist
system, it was the oversight.
So if you're going to corrupt society
with whatever decision you make as a
company, then that's going to be reflected
in people not using your product.
Sort of one. That's one model
of oversight. So we shall see
time, you know, but you, you
might even have broken the,
uh,
the political system that
enables capitalism to function
while you've changed it.
So we should see change changes
often painful. So my question is, uh,
absolutely,
it's fascinating.
You're absolutely right that there were
zero oversight on algorithms that can
have a profound civilization
changing a effect.
So do you think it's possible?
I mean I haven't,
have you seen government,
so do you think is possible to
create regulatory bodies, uh,
oversight over Ai Algorithms,
which are inherently such cutting
edge set of ideas and technologies?
Yeah,
but I think it takes time to
figure out what kind of oversight,
what kinds of controls and it took time
to design the FDA regime. Uh, you know,
and some people still don't like
it and they want to fix it. Um,
and I think there are clear
ways that it could be improved,
but the whole notion that you have
stage one, stage two, stage three,
and here are the criteria for what you
have to do to pass the stage one trial.
Right? We haven't even thought about
what those would be for algorithms.
So I mean,
I think there are,
there are things we could do
right now with regard to bias.
For example, we have a pretty
good technical handle on, uh,
how to detect algorithms that are
propagating bias that exists in datasets,
um, how to de bias, those
algorithms, um, and,
and even what it's going
to cost you to do that.
So I think we could start
having some standards on that.
I think there are,
there are things to do with
impersonation of falsification
that we could, we could work on.
So I thanks.
Yeah.
Or in a very simple point. So
impersonation ism is a machine, uh,
acting as if it was a person.
I can't see a real justification for why
we shouldn't insist that machine self
identify as machines. Uh, you know, where,
where is the social benefit in,
in fooling people into thinking that
this is really a person when it isn't,
you know, I don't mind if it uses a human
light voice that's easy to understand,
that's fine, but it should just say, oh,
I'm a machine in some shape, some form,
and not many are speaking to that.
I would think relatively obvious facts.
So I think most people,
it's actually a law in California
that bands impersonation,
but only in certain restricted
circumstances. So, uh,
for the purpose of engaging in a forging
and transaction and for the purpose of
modifying someone's voting
behavior. Uh, so those are,
those are the circumstances where,
uh, machines have to self identify.
Um, but I think there's, you
know, arguably it should be
in all circumstances. Um,
and then when you, when you
talk about deep fakes, you know,
we're just beginning,
but already it's possible to make
a movie of anybody saying anything,
uh,
in ways that are pretty hard to detect,
including yourself because
you're on camera now and
your voice is coming through
with a high riser.
Yeah. As, as a,
you could take what I'm saying and replace
it with a pretty much anything else
you wanted me to be saying. And even it
would change my lips and expressions,
expressions to fit. And, uh,
there's actually not much in the way of
a real legal protection against that.
I think in the commercial area
you could say, yeah, that's a,
you're using my brand. And so on that,
there, there are rules about that,
but in the political sphere, I think it's,
uh, at, at the moment it's, you know,
anything goes. So, and that, that
could be really, really damaging.
And let me just, uh, tried
to make, not an argument,
but try to look back at history and a
say something a dark in essence is while
regulation seems to be oversight seems
to be exactly the right thing to do here.
It seems that human beings,
what they naturally do is they
wait for something to go wrong.
If you're talking about nuclear weapons,
you can't talk about nuclear weapons
being dangerous until somebody actually
like the United States drops
the bomb or Chernobyl melting.
Do you think we will have to wait
for things going wrong in a way
that's obviously damaging to society?
Not An existential risk, but
obviously damaging. Okay.
Or do you have faith that,
I hope not, but I mean,
I think we do have to look
at history and uh, you know,
so the two examples you gave UCLE
weapons and nuclear power are very,
very interesting because, you
know, when nuclear weapons,
we knew in the early years of the 20th
century that atoms contained a huge
amount of energy, right? We had
equals MC squared. We knew the,
the mass differences between the
different atoms and their components.
And we knew that
you might be able make an
incredibly powerful explosive.
So Hg wells wrote science fiction book,
I think in 1912.
Um, Frederick Saudi, who was
the guy who discovered isotopes,
a Nobel Prize winner,
he gave a speech in 1915 saying that,
you know,
one pound of this new explosive would be
the equivalent of 150 tons of dynamite,
which turns out to be about
right. And, uh, you know,
this was in World War One,
right?
So he was imagining how much
worse the World War would be,
uh,
if we were using that kind of explosive.
But the physics establishment simply
refused to believe that these things could
be made, including the people
who are making it well.
So they were doing the nuclear physics,
I mean eventually wore the ones who made
it and Jaguar for me or whoever. Well,
so up to, um, the, the development, uh,
was,
was mostly theoretical.
So it was people using sort of primitive
kinds of particle acceleration and
doing experiments, uh, at the,
at the level of single particles are
collections of particles that they,
they weren't
yet thinking about how to actually
make a bomb or anything like that,
but they knew the energy it was there
and they figured if they understood it
better, uh, it might be possible,
but the physics establishment,
their view, and I think because
they did not want it to be true,
the view was that it could not be true,
uh,
that this could not provide
a way to make a super weapon.
And, um, you know,
there was this famous speech given by
Rutherford who was the sort of leader of
nuclear physics. And, um,
it was on September 11th, 1933.
And he, he said, you know,
anyone who talks about the possibility
of obtaining energy from transformation
of atoms is talking complete
moonshine. And, uh, the next,
uh,
the next morning,
Leo's Zelar read about that speech and
then invented the nuclear chain reaction.
And so as soon as he invented the,
as soon as he had that idea that you
could make a chain reaction with neutrons
because neutrons were not repelled by
the nuclear so they could enter the
nuclear center and think, continue the
reaction. As soon as he has that idea,
he instantly realized that
the world was in deep doodoo.
Uh,
because this is 1933,
right in a Hitler had a recently
come to power in Germany.
Zilara was in London,
uh,
and eventually became a refugee and a,
and came to the u s and the,
I'm in the process of, of having
the idea about the chain reaction.
He figured out basically how to make
a bomb and also how to make a reactor.
And he patented the reactor in 1934,
but because of the situation,
the great power conflict situation
that he could see happening, um,
he kept that a secret. And so, um,
between then and the
beginning of world war two,
people were working,
including the Germans on
how to actually create neutron sources.
Right.
What specific fission reactions would
produce neutrons have the right energy to
continue the reaction.
And,
and that was demonstrated in Germany,
I think in 1938 if I remember correctly.
The first,
uh,
nuclear weapon patent
was 1939 by the French.
Um, so this was actually a,
you know, this was actually
going on, you know, well before World War
Two really got going. And then, you know,
the British parable, he had the most
advanced capability in this area,
but for safety reasons among others and
plus, which is sort of just resources.
They moved the program from Britain to
the u s and then that became Manhattan
project. Uh, so the, the,
the reason why we couldn't
have any kind of oversight of nuclear
weapons and nuclear technology was because
we were basically already in a,
an arms race in a war.
And, um, but you, you mentioned
that in the twenties and thirties.
So what are the echoes,
the way you've described the story,
I mean, there's clearly echoes.
Why do you think most AI researchers,
folks who are really close to the metal,
a really are not concerned about AI?
They don't think about it, uh, whether
it's, they don't want to think about it.
It's, well, what are the,
yeah, why do you think that is?
What are the echoes of the
nuclear situation to the
current situation and what
can we do about it? I
think there is a, you know,
a kind of motive motivated cognition,
which is a,
a term in psychology means that you
believe what you would like to be true,
uh, rather than what is true. And, uh,
you know,
it's,
it's unsettling to think that what
you're working on might be the end of the
human race,
obviously.
So you would rather instantly deny it
and come up with some reason why it
couldn't be true. And
the, you know, I have,
I collected a long list of regions
that extremely intelligent,
competent AI scientists have come up with
for why we shouldn't worry about this.
You know,
for example,
calculators are superhuman at arithmetic
and they haven't taken over the world.
So there's nothing to worry about.
Well, okay, my five year old, you know,
could've figured out why that
was, uh, uh, an unreasonable and,
and really quite weak
argument. Um, you know,
another one was, uh, you know,
while it's theoretically possible that
you could have a super human AI destroy
the world,
you know,
it's also theoretically possible that a
black hole could materialize right next
to the earth and destroy
humanity. I mean, yes,
it's theoretically possible quantum,
theoretically extremely unlikely that
it would just materialize right there.
Um,
but that's a completely bogus and allergy
because if the whole physics community
on earth was working to materialize
a black hole in near Earth orbit,
right, wouldn't you ask them, is that
a good idea? Is that going to be safe?
You know, what if you succeed?
Right? And that's the thing, right?
The Ai community is sort of refused
to ask itself what if you succeed?
And initially I think that was
because it was too hard, but you know,
Alan Turing asked himself that
and he said we'd be toast.
Right? If we were lucky, we might
be able to switch off the power,
but preferably we'd be toast.
But there's also an aspect that,
because we're not exactly
sure what the future holds,
it's not clear exactly.
So technically what to worry about,
sort of how things go wrong. And so, uh,
there is something, it feels like,
maybe you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but there's something paralyzing about
worrying about something that logically
is inevitable, but you don't really
know what that will look like.
Yeah, I think that's, that's it's a
reasonable point. And you know, the,
you know, it's certainly in
terms of existential risks,
it's different from asteroid collides
with the earth. Right, right. Which again,
is quite possible. Uh, you
know, it's happened in the past.
It'll probably happen again. We
don't, right. We don't know right now.
But if we did detect an asteroid that
was going to hit the earth in 75 years
time, we'd certainly be doing
something about it. Well,
it's clear that he's got a big rock and
as we'll probably have a meeting and see
what do we do about the big
rock with Ai, right. Where they,
I mean there are very few people who
think it's not going to happen within the
next 75 years. I know Rod Brooks
doesn't think it's going to happen. Uh,
maybe Andrew Ng doesn't think
it's happened, but you know,
a lot of the people who work day
to day, uh, you know, as you say,
he had the rock face,
they think it's going to happen.
I think the median estimate from AI
researchers is somewhere in 40 to 50 years
from, from now when maybe
you little, you know,
I think in Asia they think it's going
to be even faster than that. I am,
I'm a little bit more conservative.
I think probably take longer than
that. But I think it's, you know,
as happened with nuclear weapons and
overnight it can happen overnight that you
have these breakthroughs and we need
more than one breakthrough. But you know,
it's on the order of half a dozen.
This is a very rough scale,
but sort of half a dozen
breakthroughs of that nature
would have to happen for us to
reach superhuman Ai. But the,
you know,
the AI research community is vast now.
The massive investments from
governments, from corporations, uh,
tons of really, really
smart people. You know,
you just have to look at the rate of
progress in different areas of AI to see
that things are moving pretty
fast. So, so to say, oh,
it's just going to be thousands of years.
I mean, I don't see any basis for that.
You know, I see, you
know, for example, the,
the, the Stanford hundred year
Ai Project, right? Which, um, is
supposed to be sort of, you know,
the serious establishment view, uh,
their most recent report actually said
it's probably not even possible. Oh,
wow.
Right.
Which if you want a perfect
example of people in denial,
that's it. Because you know,
for the whole history of Ai,
we've been saying to philosophers
who said it wasn't possible. Well,
you have no idea what you're talking
about. Of course it's possible. Right.
Give me an, give me an argument for why
it couldn't happen and there isn't one.
Right. And now because people
are worried that maybe a,
I might get a bad name or,
or I just don't want to think about this,
they are saying, okay, well of course
it's not really possible. You know,
if we imagine, right?
Imagine if, you know, the,
the leaders of the cancer
biology community, uh, got
up and said, well, you know,
of course curing cancer,
it's not really possible.
It'd be at complete outrage,
dismay,
and you know,
I find this really strange phenomenon,
so,
okay,
so if you accept that as possible and if
you accept that it's probably going to
happen.
The point that you're making that,
you know,
how does it go wrong?
A valid question without that,
without an answer to that question,
then you're stuck with what I call the
griller problem, which is, you know,
the problem that the gorillas face,
right?
They made something more
intelligent than them,
namely us a few million years ago,
and now, now they're in deep doodoo.
Uh, so there's really nothing they
can do. They've lost the control.
They failed to solve the control problem
of controlling humans. And, uh, so they,
they lost. Um, so we don't
want to be in that situation.
And if the gorilla problem is,
is the only formulation you have it,
there's not a lot you can do, right, other
than to say, okay, we should try to stop,
you know, we should just not make the
humans or in this case, not make the AI.
And I think that's
really hard to do to, uh,
and I'm not actually proposing that
that's a feasible of course of action. Um,
and I also think that if
properly controlled AI could
be incredibly beneficial.
So the,
but it seems to me that there's a,
there's a consensus that one of the major
failure modes is this loss of control.
That we create AI systems that
are pursuing incorrect objectives.
And because the AI system believes
it knows what the objective is,
it has no incentive to listen to
us anymore, so to speak. Right. It,
it's just carrying out the,
the strategy that it,
it has computed as being
the optimal solution.
And, uh, you know,
it may be that in the process it needs
to acquire more resources to increase the
possibility of success or you know,
prevent various failure modes by
defending itself against interference.
And so that collection of problems
I think is something we can address.
The other problems are roughly speaking,
you know, misuse, right? So even
if we solve the control problem,
we make perfectly safe, controllable
AI systems. Well, why, you know,
why does Dr Evil, we're
going to use those, right?
He wants to just take over the world and
he'll make unsafe AI systems but then
get out of control. So that's one
problem, which is sort of a, you know, uh,
partly a policing problem.
Parlier uh,
sort of a cultural problem for the
profession of how we teach people.
Uh,
what kinds of AI systems are safe.
You talk about autonomous weapon system
and how pretty much everybody agrees,
there's too many ways that
that can go horribly wrong.
Had this great a slot of arts movie that
kind of illustrates that beautifully.
I want to talk about that.
That's another,
there's another topic I'm
happy we talk about the,
just want to mention that what I
see is the third major failure mode,
which is overused,
not so much misuse but overuse of AI
that we become overly dependent.
So I call this the Wally problems.
If you seen Morley, the movie, all right,
all the humans are on the spaceship and
the machines look after everything for
them and they just watch TV
and drink big gulps and uh,
they're all sort of obese and stupid and,
and they sort of totally any
notion of human autonomy and um,
you know, so it in effect, right?
This would happen like those
slow boiling frog, right?
We would gradually turn over more and
more of the management of our civilization
to machines as we are already
doing. And this, you know, this,
if this process continues, you know, we,
we sort of gradually switch from sort of
being the masters of technology to just
being the guests, right? So, so
we become guests on a cruise ship,
you know, which is fine for a week,
but not, not for the rest of eternity,
you know. And it's almost
irreversible, right? Once you,
once you lose the incentive to,
for example,
learn to be an engineer or
a doctor or a sanitation,
uh, operative or, or any other of the,
the infinitely many ways that we
maintain and propagate our civilization.
You know, if you, if you don't have the
incentive to do any of that, you won't.
And then it's really hard to recover.
And of course they are just one
of the technologies that could,
that third failure mode results in that
there's probably other technology in
general detaches us from, uh,
it does a bit, but the, the,
the differences that in
terms of the knowledge to,
to run our civilization,
you know,
up to now we've had no alternative but
to put it into people's heads. Right,
right. And if you, the software
with Google, I mean, so
software in general, so cute.
The computers in general,
but, but the, you know,
the knowledge of how, you know, how
a sanitation system works, you know,
that's an AI has to understand that
it's no good putting it into Google.
So, I mean, we, we've always
put knowledge in on paper,
but paper doesn't run our civilization
and it only runs when it goes from the
paper into people's heads again,
right?
So we've always propagated
civilization through human minds.
And we've spent about a trillion person
years doing that. I literally write,
and you can,
you can work it out.
It's about right is about just over
100 billion people who've ever lived.
And uh,
each of them has spent about 10 years
learning stuff to keep their civilization
going. And, uh, so that's a trillion
person years we put into this effort,
beautiful way to this hand, all of
civilization. And now we're, you know,
we're in danger of throwing that away.
So this is a problem that AI can't solve.
It's not a technical problem. It's
a, you know, if we do our job right,
the AI systems will say, you
know, the human race doesn't,
in the long run want to be
passengers and a cruise ship.
The human race wants autonomy.
This is part of human preferences.
So we, the AI systems are not
going to do this stuff for you.
You've got to do it for yourself,
right?
I'm not going to carry you to the top
of Everest in an autonomous helicopter.
You have to climb it if you want to
get the benefit. Um, and so on. So,
but I'm afraid that because
we are short sighted and lazy,
we're going to override the AI systems.
And,
and there's an amazing short story that
I recommend to everyone that I talk to
about this called the machine stops
written in 1909 by Ian Forster,
who,
you know,
wrote novels about the British Empire
and sort of things that became costume
dramas on the BBC. But he wrote
this one science fiction story,
which is an amazing vision of the future.
It has,
it has basically iPads. Uh, it has
video conferencing, it has moocs.
Uh, it has computer, computer
induced obesity. I mean,
literally it's what people spend their
time doing is giving online courses or
listening to online courses and,
and, and talking about ideas.
But they never get out there in the real
world that they don't really have a lot
of face to face contact. Uh,
everything is done online, you know,
so all the things we're worrying about
now, uh, were described in the story and,
and then the human race becomes more
and more dependent on the machine,
loses knowledge of how
things really run a,
and then becomes vulnerable to
collapse. And, uh, so it's, uh,
it's a pretty unbelievably amazing story
for someone writing in 1909 to two.
Imagine all this less.
Yeah.
So there's very few people that represent
artificial intelligence more than you
suit Russell, if you say, okay,
so it was all my fault. It's all right.
Um,
you're often brought up as the
person while Stuart Russell,
like the AI person is worried about this.
That's why you should be worried about,
do you feel the burden of that?
I don't know if you feel that at all,
but when I talk to people like from it,
you talk about people
outside of computer science,
when they think about this still
Russell, uh, is worried about AI safety.
You should be worried too.
Do you feel the burden of that?
I mean in a practical sense,
uh, yeah, because, uh,
I get, uh, you know, a dozen,
sometimes 25 invitations
a day to talk about it,
to give interviews, to write
press articles and so on. So, um,
in that very practical sense,
I'm seeing that people are concerned
and really interested about this. Um,
by you worried that you could be wrong
as all good scientists are. Of course,
I worry about that all the time. I mean,
that's, that's always been the way that I,
I worked, you know, is like I have
an argument in my head with myself,
right? So I have, I have
some idea and I think, okay,
how could that be wrong? Or did
someone else already have that idea?
So I'll go and search and
as much literature as I can
and to see whether someone
else already thought of that
or, or even refuted it. So,
you know, I, right now I'm reading
a lot of philosophy because
you know, in, in the form of the debate,
so over utilitarianism
and other kinds of moral,
uh, moral formula formulas
shouldn't, shall we say,
people have already thought through
some of these issues. But you know what,
one of the things I'm, I'm not
seeing in a lot of these debates is,
is this specific idea about,
uh,
the importance of uncertainty
in the objective, um,
that this is the way we should think
about machines that are beneficial to
humans.
So this idea of,
of provably beneficial machines based on,
uh,
explicit uncertainty in the objective.
Um, you know, it seems to be,
you know, my, my gut feeling
is this is the core of it.
It's going to have to be elaborated in
a lot of different directions and there
are a lot of really beneficial, yeah. But
they're there. I mean, it has to be right.
We can't afford, you know, hand wavy
beneficial because they're, you know,
whenever we do hand wavy stuff,
there are loopholes.
And the thing about super intelligent
machines is they find the loopholes,
you know, just like, you
know, tax evaders. Uh,
if you don't write your tax
little properly that people
will find the loopholes
and end up paying no tax and, and, uh,
so you should think of it this way
and getting those definitions right.
You know,
it is really a long process,
you know,
so you can,
you can define mathematical frameworks
and within that framework you can prove
mathematical theorems
that yes, this, this,
this theoretical entity will be provably
beneficial to that theoretical entity.
But that framework may not match
the real world in some crucial way,
a long process of thinking through it to
iterating and so on. Last question. Yep.
Uh,
you have 10 seconds to answer it.
What is your favorite
Scifi movie about Ai?
I would say interstellar has
my favorite robots or beets?
Topsy. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So, so Taz, the robots,
one of the robots in interstellar
is the way a robot should behave.
And,
uh,
I would say x Makena is in some ways the
one that's the one that makes you think
a, in a nervous kind of way about,
about where we're going. Osser sir,
thank you so much for talking today.
Pleasure.